o'brien major league baseball draft
that's going to begin also this weekend
on sunday
and a loss fagin has a chance to become
a first round pick
john treach found this gorman grad just
out there grinding through the heat just
a few days before his big day
john that's right 36 young men will go
down in history as 20 21 major league
baseball first round draft picks
it's an honor with great power comes
great responsibility
and that's a great thing for gorman
gayle tyler whitaker
he has prodigious power the ball sounds
different blasting off of his back it
rockets it reverberates
it reels in interest from every major
league baseball team
nevada gatorade player of the year tyler
whitaker is committed to the university
of arizona
but an mlb team could pick him high and
heave hundreds
of thousands of dollars his way on
sunday or monday whitaker is honored to
follow in the las vegas star footprints
of bryce harper chris bryant and joey
gallo
it could be a life-changing next 72
hours for the southern nevada slugger
it's motivation for me i want to be i
want to be at the
level of those guys and all the great
baseball players that have come through
vegas and
i've just been working hard and it's
paid off so far so
i'm not slowing down by any means but
it's nice to
to reap the benefits of my my hard work
i've been committed since i was in
eighth grade to arizona and
whatever happens happens but i'm ready
for both outcomes if i
if my path is going professionally i'm
ready for it but if
i do go to college i'm super super
stoked to go
go to university of arizona first round
the draft to sunday and continues into
monday and tuesday